yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
hello
hello
are we alive
i started like five minutes early like
three minutes early
so
we'll see
hi
hi zombie
a yoru
i'm really good how are you man
why is the chat why are you all the same
color
on screen
is that a thing
hi andrew
[Music]
hi ahmad
hey manga man
sup sup sup sup sup
your comments show top right on the
screen
but everyone's green
wouldn't you all want to be different
colors
imagine you could choose your own color
like a website we won't talk about
that'd be kind of nice right you choose
your own color
because in the youtube chat like the
normal chat you're all
like gray
unless you're a member
then you're green
hi space bean
good morning
hello everybody
[Music]
this your go-to channel for ra
elden ring lore really
hmm
well thank you
hi hi hi hi hi
so i have new alerts for stuff or new
alert sounds that i think you guys will
like
if somebody subscribes to the channel it
makes this sound hello
shows at the bottom of the
screen that's alexander
i'll do it two more times hello
i love it
can you play dark souls 2 no i don't
like dark souls 2.
there you go
so we have
that sound for subscribers
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
cam
hi hi hi hi jennifer
please stop spamming high i see you
please stop
cut it out right now
cut it out
all right one more high and you're done
i'm just saying
if i see it
okay
you want i'm gonna time you out anyway
calm down
i'm not skipping dark souls 2. i tried
it
for about six hours
i don't like it
i don't like dark souls 2.
i don't want to play it
it gives me a headache every time i
think of that game
oh we have other alerts too
let's see so we have that's subscribers
is alexander going hello
yeah i have like a thousand hours in
sakiro
thank you maj
um okay so this is for new members
forefathers
it's one of my favorite lines in the
game bro
i love that sound
that that line by godric is so good
so that's memberships
and then we got uh
bear witness nice
wow that didn't sound good and then we
have super chats
y'all hate that sound right ancient
elden ring slash roots of death i don't
know that's just what someone said one
of the last super chats we got so
i think those are the new ones i think
there's another one for gifted some
gifted memberships
can i even find one of those
uh
i have to like go in my thing
has anyone even gifted a membership here
no i don't think so
well there's new sounds that i thought
would be fun
oh it's really melania blade of nicola
oh i have to do
reichardt don't i i'll make one of those
i will absolutely make one of those
we gotta do
i'll i'll make one of those i didn't
even think of that for some reason
how random did you make the randomizer
um
it's just plain random so every item
that we're picking up today is
completely random
except for like base no i don't know it
i didn't really understand like what the
mod was telling me
it was just like
i put it at like 40 bias as to where
it's like not crazy like not insane
where we can never get an item that we
actually need without this running
around
uh
i mean look look at this guys like
tell tell me
just give me a random starting class
because it doesn't matter
like my character is gonna look so
stupid no matter what
it it even randomizes your starting
class not the levels
but the starting class
okay prisoner that's the first thing i
saw look at this
what the [ __ ]
i don't know what he's holding
looks like a crystalline
staff he has literally two staffs
so i mean we could go to another one
it'll be totally different like you guys
are saying
what was the second one bandit
bandit
oh
looks pretty basic not gonna lie
let's look at samurai
the heck is this
interesting setup we got going on here
nihil
i think that was the roth spear let's
just go with wretch whatever we're just
gonna go with whatever wretches okay
this makes the most sense to start with
nothing basically
let's do it
wow
this is too basic
what is that sword it looks cool
all right i guess we start with this
what's our name
[Music]
yeah that's really not bad for a wretch
i guess there wasn't enough like items
on that character
to uh
[Music]
to actually randomize let me look at a
vagabond really quick
[Music]
i don't know what do you guys think we
should do
hello
i found that plasti-duce can be an
absolute pain i love that boss fight
though
hello
rick jr i love that
well let's go with wretch
makes sense
we're gonna get random items that we
pick up anyway and then we'll be rick jr
hey we need to go see like who rick is
because all the bosses are randomized
all the enemies are randomized i think
all the normal
enemies i could have made it to where
all of like the wildlife would be random
[ __ ] too
we're gonna we're just gonna do random
like
40 bias like not anything that crazy and
just like kind of play the game
if we want to do this again
we will and we'll we'll make it nuts
this is my first time
we're gonna go with this guy right here
for obvious reasons
i don't think keepsakes are random no
they're not give me that golden seed
all right let's do it
can you imagine if rick is the elden
beast
oh all of the enemies are scaled as well
i should have mentioned that so like if
we see melania out front like
right outside the gates here
uh
it's gonna be fine i saw your post on
the new video i'm very hyped i can't
wait uh we should talk about that real
quick yeah
i think so
so if if y'all didn't know i am making
an elden ring
um it's called the great path ahead
which is going to be like a cinematic
depiction
of
the lore
so
it's not gonna be
me sitting here
narrating things that i think happen
right
it's going to be like i'm literally
voice acting a character in a story
and i think i decided that i'm gonna do
it in a tv show type style
so like one new episode will come out a
week
and then once we like get all of it done
i can make it into one big video that
seemed to be
the thing
it's like it'll have a character in the
game
that
goes through the great path that we all
know
is eldon ring
and but it will be like from the
perspective of like a tarnish to is
actually there and like
saying [ __ ] does that make like you guys
ever like
like when you walk into the melania
fight have you ever thought to yourself
like why isn't my character telling her
where mikla is
right
kind of like that garbage man except i'm
not going to be explaining like anything
i'm going to put it in a way to where
like you can understand the lore a bit
more this way
but
it's just a different type of depiction
that i have not seen before
thank you femi i know i look good but it
is kind of like that garbage man except
for literally everything
like a movie but i think i'm gonna do it
in the style of a tv show where one new
episode comes out a week
so like the first episode would be
called the grafted
that's how i have it titled right now
y'all know what that means
the ring of woke
so i hope you all look forward to that
it's gonna take me a long time to make
this like there's a lot of work that
goes into this
i recently just finished
and i want you to think about this i
recently just finished
recording every
single voice line in this game
just so i can use it wherever i want
where i played the game with no sound
other than sound effects and recorded
and organized in folders every single
voice line every single cinematic
took a long time
so now i have it all organized and now i
can kind of create
shots um that makes sense to the story
that we're trying to tell
so i'm really really excited for it i
think you guys will like it
a lot
i really do
but i want your opinion on something
before we start
yeah it's really hard
um
i was thinking about being a little
funny like the the character that i'm
voice acting
i don't know whether to whether to make
it like really serious
in cinematic
like that kind of matches elden ring or
kind of play off of it
and kind of be myself
you know what i mean
i'm not i i haven't really decided on
what i want to do there yet but once i
like start it i can get going
i think it could be a little bit of both
rocket cat
where there are serious moments and then
there's
funny moments
right
wait sorry there's something on my other
screen
old okay there we go
yeah it's not gonna be like
it's always just a comedy right
it i think a little mix
with serious moments and funny moments
um
that could be good so that's that's what
i was thinking of doing i just wasn't
like you gotta pick a style and stick to
it you know what i'm saying
[Music]
or else then you're
then what i'm making would be all over
the place and it'd be like what
yeah
but i'm literally going to be uh voice
acting a character i've never voice
acted in my life it's just gonna be my
normal voice
but we'll see
all right let's get started
let's do the randomizer i just hope you
guys uh look forward to that i'm excited
for it
okay so that like we literally need that
to get out of here so i'm glad it just
gave me that
yeah i don't know about that pro but i
just hope you like it that's it
is character gonna have starting weapons
and armor and get better stuff um
no
you'll see man i don't want to tell you
guys too much i just know you're really
going to like it i'm going to ban
jennifer for being an idiot
and just spamming letters constantly
let's get rid of that let's just get
that the heck out of here
i timed him or her out
and then they're back all right let's
see what we got here
i did a test of this last night and for
some reason the grafted cyan still jump
forward i think it's because oh never
mind
what the
hello
oh
there we go
whoa whoa whoa
nice
is it too loud for you guys
are you good
that's not fair
okay i need to turn down my headset then
i don't know what the heck that is but i
don't like it
my fickle ears
let's go
grafton crystallion
and we got a cookbook for that
we got the this is actually a really
good cookbook holy [ __ ]
nice
those bosses are so easy those
crystallines
let's go
god my character is ugly
ugh i love it
all right guys
yeah that's the sleep cookbook right
may i can make sleeping pots and stuff
yeah because it's definitely scaled as
well guardian
the um
oh my god my character looks so stupid
is melania gonna be different here
because i had it to where the npcs have
different clothes on
as well
i'm so hairy what the [ __ ]
i don't think i just want to see if
melania looks different
i don't think or sorry melinda i don't
know why i'm saying melania
i don't think she would
hey my character is a girl
just
doesn't shave
nope she looks exactly the same
all right we gotta go see rick right we
have to go see rick
this isn't even a question we literally
have to
watch it's gonna be like [ __ ]
malacath in there dude
hey wait let me turn down my headset
because it's it's kinda nuts
i ain't even gonna lie
oh
hello
can we not
can we not the red main soldier
oh
i hate you
did i miss
hello
excuse me
since when can they do that
oh god
not a good start
um they should be scaled it didn't seem
like it
i'm the guy that asked about dark souls
3 after elden ring if you remember i
loved it
bro dark souls 3 is amazing
i am i'm going to stream uh bloodborne
i think i'm going to start that this
week
all right
avoiding running
gargoyle
don't like that
you i can hear them slapping their feet
who's up there
wait if i pick these up no okay so the
items on the ground are the same
we got a little snaily boy here
oh god
yeah we're definitely gonna stream
bloodborne it's a frenzied rat
excellent
i'm dead it's over
i died
a normal soldier
i just want to see who the boss is
what
he's invisible
it's doable
no it's not no it's not
oh oh god
what happened to rick
dad
[Music]
i need to learn how to fight a bear
again
i want to know what we get when we beat
it
do you get anything if you kill soldier
of godric like does an item drop
it's baron time
rick's been infected with the bear
how how how
wow
damn
do we need a death counter
that's way too much work
no
well too bad all right let's go
bro
bro
okay i like that i like that a lot
let me stab your face
just keep track in chat
okay he gets staggered really easy
well i'm doing no damage that doesn't
help either
this
bill
chill
no i wanted to hit him a couple times
this reminds me of the guardian ape
please don't kill me
have y'all ever seen that
animation
wow
first time i've ever seen that
i got a bear hug that was so close bro
yeah it's scaled
it just doesn't seem like it
i got cuddled to death i love that for
me
it's a good thing he gets staggered
well while trying to be my friend he
killed me
it's not a good friend
it's two of those
to get him to stagger
two square offs
wouldn't let me do it
there we go
easy peasy
all right what do i get
400 runes
that was not worth it at all
all right let's go see
who the uh the tree sentinel is oh
what's this item
you have to pay attention wow i love
that that's a great item
a [ __ ] emote
zero deaths you know what you know why
we don't need a death counter because
i'm not gonna die i haven't yet
obviously
you're right he dropped nothing
it was an awful item
you dropped nothing
oh is that what you get like
do you get that emote there
interesting yeah i lost 3k runes
and i got him back look at that
that's pretty good
hold up
man
damn
he thick
all right i'm ready for this
let's go
no i hate it already
that's a big no for me guys i i ain't
gonna [ __ ] around with that
dog what are you wearing
uh
gargoyles
what are you wearing do you sound the
same oh yes
tarnished are we
come to the lands between is this what
he looks like
of course you have
no shame in it
unfortunately for you
however yeah i know i'm maidenless [ __ ]
you all right what are we gonna get if
we go to the dragon
let me get torrent first
i i am not messing with that i'm sorry
i'm just not i'm just not
faces aren't randomized i didn't think
they would be able to do that so that's
that's vary's real face
that's kind of cool
that's neato
oh that's kenneth's heights robe you're
right
i ran past
your mom last night
does cauli look exactly the same
okay i'm getting a lot of golden runes
right now
you're a tarnish yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right let me see what this is
lightning spear
that's not bad and smithing stone three
that's kind of random
we'll take it we'll take it
what the heck is that
is that a little fire slug
okay
you can chill right there my guy
one of those goofballs
oh
no thanks i do not like their style
wait do i get a different item for
killing this guy
where is it
is it up top
okay so those are the same
old
everybody hold
what do i get
no you don't even get an item for that
i'm stupid
what about butterflies those are the
same
anything crazy is that a lobster
i see a lobster in there that is bad
check holly's shop
ooh
i should do that i'll go back i'll go
back
let's get torrent
oh is that a different butterfly
okay so what if i pick up this mushroom
that's a melted mushroom
that guy looks the same
oh there's the lobster
we got one of the worm faces over there
okay
he's up top
you think that guy will jump down like
the giant
was that a different mushroom
yeah why would i get a melted mushroom
right
you thought this was a normal video no
you're live right now dude you can ask
me whatever you guys want
oh we're gonna check how every boss is
another thing guys for me to get to the
final boss i have to get all seven great
runes
so we gotta go and find everybody to
even get access to the radigon fight
traveler
from beyond the fog
how do batteries work
um
magic
i'm gonna stream till 3 p.m cst so
another three and a half hours
i
offer you an accord
i wish there was a mod where right when
this fades out there's a honda accord
right behind her
would that not be hilarious
i offer you an accord then it's settled
this is a honda accord parked right
there by grace
to turn runes into strength
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay at least i get
the whistle i was kind of curious if
she'd give me something random
yeah yeah yeah
yes i do i have to sell them
let's uh
equip this here
let's go back to kale
which is going to trigger ronnie
vigor arcane build
[Music]
this way hey melanis or ronnie's the
same
yo yo yo a pleasure to meet you is she
still going to give me the summoning
thing
i can call yeah i can't i was in trust
by torrance
okay i still get the important stuff but
she gave me two smithing stones and not
the wolves that's funny
forth spirits
summon them with the spirits now it is
that thank you ronnie i appreciate you
how long will it be
before tan is tired of obeisance to the
two fingers
yeah yeah yeah
probably wake the [ __ ] up
you're a top and i can also that you're
not then why not i am carly
uh sell
yup yup yup yup
purchase
what is this [ __ ]
who's ax axe of godric
get oslo's helmet
the dragon claw shield
neat
uh might want that
okay
cool
receive bell bearing what
oh thank you
i think that's part of the mod all right
goodbye yeah yeah yeah um
where did where should we go now
let me go back here
should we see what the dragon is i'm
kind of curious
i should level that's what i no [ __ ]
quick
all right we're good wait meld i can
talk here
this tiny golden aura oh yeah
she usually says that up the hill
upon the cliff a demigod yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i think we level vigor first
moog
millicent
dung eater
huge
i do like huge
you guys like bach
i think box a
little weenie hut junior
um why is the dragon already there
is he just chilling
fire giant the fellowman
godfrey
wait that's the magic dragon oh
is that blide
what are you doing man
what is happening here
oh hello
leave me be
i think this is a no-go boys
this is a big old no-go over here
can i get something different here
let's go
who's that tom [ __ ] back at it again
i can't be on this
thank you for the two dollars i
appreciate it man
you can take them i don't think so let's
go see who patches is
and
i'm assuming something different will
spawn here
thank you tom
oh god
the [ __ ] bowling ball
america's source let's go
that's a big talisman
i like it
you heard melania that's my uh alert
all right let's see who this is
let me put that on
excellent
is it still bloody finger
who are you
raven mount assassin
wow
uh
okay
that that bleed
was nuts holy [ __ ]
all right
we'll go to we'll go over here
let me do this
i'll grab the map as well
i was just taught a lesson a hundred
percent
dude
this setup over here is weird
wait wait wait wait i should see what's
in this chest
is this not normal
he's a hot dog and bun technically
considered a sandwich
yes a hot dog is a sandwich
gold
what is that
a hot dog is a sandwich
a dragon heart okay
thank you for the five dollars rob i
appreciate that
thank you very much
it is totally a sandwich
it is
meat in between bread
sandwich
okay those look like just regular ass
flowers
i can't even grab those never mind
some things are different some things
aren't
i feel like that's normal
can i sneak like
if i get up and jump is he gonna know
okay we're gonna have to we're gonna bop
nope i don't like that
i don't like that boys
there we go
okay
this is hard let's see what's in here
hey thanks rob oh okay i'll take the key
i'll take the key that's fine
i didn't even know those flowers could
move around
okay let's go see who margaret is
out of pure curiosity
wolf is big chilling
you stay nope
nope
oh god
i want to see if this guy jumps
he does not jump
okay old fang
we should see what all these are
beast bone
oh no
oh god
leave me be
ratagon's puppy
the things i'm picking up off the ground
are what they look like
are they not normally there
golden seed in a gold rune
i bet rodericka looks weird
where's she at
is there a chest
oh
she looks cool
everyone's
been grafted
everyone who came with me
i love the outfit changes for me they
fought
for me
only to have their arms taken
their legs taken like she actually looks
good
taken not as good as me
taken and stuck
to the spider
did you know a chest at the camp oh
you're right we'll come back
there's lots of items it's quite a lock
when you think about it all right thank
you
um do i have anything different do i
have any armor
no
all right let's go pick [ __ ] up over
here
this is usually smithing stones
excellent
raw meat dumpling
we got a ball up here
already aggroed
very good
all these items
guys i am going to miss stuff don't yell
at me
it's okay i promise
roon
golden rune
where are all these balls coming from
man
yelling ooh somber two okay okay that
was worth
those worth
wait do you guys think alexander's gonna
look different
oh no how we gonna break this
i guess we don't have to
no
oh
okay
okay
i mean sure
i'll take it
excellent
what is that
that's a faith and strength
ooh
that could be good we're gonna hold on
to that we are gonna hold on to that
dude it's a golden goat
it's a dead golden goat
i'm curious of what alexander looks like
night of the derp knives
hello
hello
can you hear me
help me
i'm stuck
hello
[Music]
can you hear me yep help me i'm stuck yo
i wonder what he gives me wait
i'm
loving this oh thank you jay herbin
thank you for the 10 super chat i'm glad
you like it man thank you
give it your all right
he's gonna give me nine runes
but thank you herman get some w's in the
chat
w what do you guys do on youtube like
what do you do when you get excited
are you guys like a w squad
like yeah
huge win
i don't know
should we make up our own thing
yeah i'm gonna try and do a full
playthrough not all today but throughout
the week
but thank you
ouch
triumphant delight that's normal
you guys do pog here
well all right what does he give me
thank you
and
as a token of my appreciation
i'd like you to have this
gravity stone chunk thanks man
once again
let's get it
i think that's all we had to say to him
that's a lobster we don't [ __ ] around
with that
all right
i'll stop stalling we'll go we'll go to
margaret
oh god
what the heck was that
you could kill him i don't want to kill
him oh god a hand
what does bernal look like
i keep getting distracted because
everything's different
who's still following me
stop it
wow bernal what do you got
what
what
what is right here
what
sorry
i have to go to the side not seen you
before yeah
let me ask are
long gloves prosthesis
acidity
uh this isn't awful but
kind of trash not floating your boat eh
no
no
okay let's go
[ __ ] you
what's this
we'll take it
we're just trying to get any armor
honestly
i'm lost okay here we go
no i don't want to do him yet we'll come
back we'll come back
let me grab this item too
are you what
okay we're getting some interesting
items off the rip here
magma whip candlestick
i like it
we can't use it yet what is that faith
and dex okay
oh do i have a flask
sorry i'm bad it seems like we want to
do a faith build
we're getting a lot of faith items but
then again we're getting random [ __ ] all
over the place so
that could quickly change
is that a really rare weapon
nice
give me something different
get back here you forehead
nice
these are better taking them
okay gross we got a bear
these guys seem pretty normal except for
that
how
leave me be
this is very funny so far i'm enjoying
this a lot
okay i don't need to talk to melania
let's go
is roger going to look different
yup
all right take your take your bets who's
this gonna be
let's find out
i don't think they look different in the
cut scenes though
[Music]
let's see
are you kidding what the [ __ ]
they're all just stacked up man
[Laughter]
they're all just stacked
get down here
what are you crawling on
get out of the way kids
you're gonna hurt all our kids
they're just falling
oh god here we go
stop it
get down here
this is so dumb
stop singing
i love how the music is still markets
what happens if we go to stage two
he still has his voice
warrior blood must truly run in thy
veins
my god i'm stuck
[Music]
this is so weird
i love it
no phase two
granola the fel omen
roger is completely unhelpful
nice
i can't move
i can't see
where am i right now
oh
get down here
let's go
oh they all dead we got a golden seed
and the
a cuckoo
glintstone
why is she still here
she was saying all that what the heck
why are you here why are you here
i think this is what she does after you
kill her phase one
this is weird
interesting
okay
thank you
what did i get again
forgive me now she's gone
i've been
testing you
to see whether or not grace trend it
does i am clearly amazing
i can take a gathering plate
very well
i wasn't going to look at her feet
for butter moment you always want to see
your feet
every time i got another golden seed
we're getting a lot of those
every time we fight ronaldo on the
stream all of you guys want to see his
feet
it's hilarious all right what are we
wearing here
coryn you look s actually really cool
i actually like this
vagabond i don't know what that hat is
he like dude this is a good way to like
get some drip inspiration
he's wearing uh morgot's
armor cool
oh my god gideon
what is this
no we can't see his
eyes is this what giddy looks like
he's so ugly
oh this is a rare occasion yeah i bet it
is
okay
what do you look like
is that ranalas
what the [ __ ]
kind of cool
all right
look absolutely the witch nbc video
oh you're right i saw that
i saw that a long time ago
anybody anything
is it would this be a different boss i'm
going to be careful i don't want to lose
my runes
i have any yeah i got some poppy boys
what is huge gonna look like probably
normal
yeah he doesn't really have any yeah
you're a new face no matter loud europe
oh i should check out the twin maidens
too let me let me buy these sell these
let me level
what do you guys think we should
actually put points into like we gotta
we gotta choose this oh i'll check fia
let's get a hug from this greetings this
is the champion
i am fear
circumstances great champions we're
gonna hug her doing so and you do you
think it's where i come from
nice trip
honestly
you guys saying faith and strength do
you think so okay
that i don't think that could go really
wrong
you are
very warm
i am very warm
what you felt light up inside you
was a baldicon's blessing though it is
but a fleeting thing i am afraid
come back to me
should you require another well you guys
don't like your drip um i think she
looks great
via always looks great
faith and qual what's quality
i look so amazing
look at fia's feet
he's wearing boots
the touch of a woman
she still gave me a baldicon's blessing
okay let's let's do this
intel decks
um
let's get that to 20.
we got seven more let's do
four three
cool with that with that doesn't matter
we can probably hopefully respect
renault is dead we're not looking at
ronaldo okay where do we go now where do
you guys want to go
i'm gonna go here
dee's not there because we haven't seen
them yet
yeah we did not get the talisman pouch
that is true up twin maidens i said i
would do that and then i didn't
i do not want to go off that balcony but
i will let's do it [ __ ] it
what you got purchase
oh wow okay so we got blide's helmet
wargots
her sword
carrying gardner that's pretty good
another golden seed
which might not be bad
i'm actually gonna buy it
sacred tier
lights helmet
ripple blade
blitz stone wet blade a memory stone
we need to come back here
we need to come back here yeah that's
actually a lot of really good stuff
actually good
jackson arcane with more got sword
hmm let's just venture on
try and fight a bleed weapon i mean this
is all gonna come from us just doing
random [ __ ]
i can't imagine how bad
the the castle is
i thought morgot's sword was really good
right balcony see how distracted i get
you got to keep me in check
i get so distracted
all right who we got who we got
hello
preceptor miriam
nope i don't like that
don't like that
best dash of war in the game just saying
easy
give me good stuff
you gave me a [ __ ] torch
[ __ ] you
where's the cipher blade
imagine giving me a torch
is there another item where down there
oh
oh over here you're right
what i thought this was uh
only in the oh
okay cool
electrify armament
is that a faith
thingy
i think it is a faith thingy
that could be useful
we are definitely gonna keep that
is there an item back here
no okay
what's crazy about this mod is we can
find like the coolest stuff just laying
anywhere
i don't want to use those stone blade
things yet
workout sword is good but requirements
is the only bad thing about it okay i i
figured it was good
hmm trying to think
do you are you going to give me
different incantations
i teach and explore so that one day
ensuring by the way
you also
yeah dude
okay
night maidens missed
shadow bait darkness black blade dragon
bullet blessing
blame a frenzy could be really good
greatly increases fire damage negation
that's not really that big
why are we we're getting so much faith
stuff
may the golden order i'm putting i'm
putting points in faith
that's the vibe i'm getting
um should we just go south
uh let's go fight
no the dragons seem like a total [ __ ]
i don't want to go to the fog wall
let's fight this guy
oh god
really
isn't this the one in the forbidden area
i think it is
i'm dead
ah
i healed in time
paladin build
he's so tall
you're kind of a [ __ ] to fight
oh no
everybody run
ow
thank you tom
w
what
this ain't happening
is that a dodgeable attack
it's a big no-go voice
how
you have to run and dodge through it to
let him pass over you ah
that makes sense
ah
did i use the thing
oh [ __ ]
yeah i already used the things
the seeds
should i try again
i don't know
our weapons kind of suck right now
let's go this way
well salin will be there
but she'll look different
the dragon had literally like blind
shadow
underneath there
i'm gonna say no to that one as well
let's check euro
i think we need to do that when we're a
bit stronger
i don't like anything
any of that none of that
ah she does have a boss
dripped out my man dripped out ah
you must be the new tarnished yeah
so stay clear
excellent are you what is that
hello
i thought that was plaster dewsacks for
a second
oh we got an item
smithing stone three room five
glintstone breath
this seems a bit
far away for you to do that sir please
stop please stop
a bomb
man you guys are really attracted to
these people huh
all right let before i get distracted
let's just go to salad we're going to go
to selling
i'm curious what she has
and what the boss will be right before
her
and there's some items over here
stone sword claw mark seal that's big
radon's gauntlets
huge
in stone one
golden arrows
go ahead and throw those on
what are you doing
what is this
all right let's see
can i use lightning spear
oh
mad onyx lord
not fair
not fair
nice
on
let's go
that was a really small area to get
meteorite struck
just saying
all right you guys want to see hot
i mean [ __ ] i've seen selen's face
selling is hot bro
no it's all wrapped up
you can tell she's hot though tarnished
are we
no wonder you should turn up here i am
why are you here
she's wearing shoes
well
this is a cool fit don't you think if
you were like a sorcerer
do you still
very well yes i still want to learn but
show me what you got
it's still mostly spells here imagine
that's pretty good
night shard crystal release pretty basic
not
terrible
not in thought thank you
all right
if you haven't seen like go look up what
selling looks like she's actually
extremely good looking
i want this item
leave me alone
oh i can't grab it unless it's stopped
i forget
everyone in chat has a foot fetish and i
don't know why what is this
some freaking meat bro
me
um
i'm gonna go this way
let's get the boring area out of the way
it is so weird seeing these random
enemies like this
just makes no sense
i love it
who has the best feet your mom
what
what
he got replaced
what
love it
give me something good or nothing that's
fine
what we got in here
who do you think is going to be
i shouldn't have done that
another one
what
damn bro chill
okay
that's unfortunate
nice shot idiot
this is not an easy one
i think
i wonder if i have any upgrades
i don't want to put upgrades though in
like a weapon we're not really going to
use
i could have had blind help that's true
i think we can do it though i mean very
clearly we can do it
[ __ ] you
dude that reaches nuts
bruh
calm down let's go
not bad not bad not bad not bad
glintstone craftsman's cookbook
that's kind of lame
freaking lame
you're surprised how little i've i
killed you [ __ ] you respawn
thank
you okay let's go this way
no
anything but a lobster
anything
literally anything but a lobster
do i die from this height
[ __ ] yeah i don't
okay lobster avoided wait was that an
item
nope i'm blind and stupid
we tried to go to patches and we got
absolutely bodied
okay i guess there's nothing manning
that smithing stone one
golden rune
why are you not suffering because i'm
having fun we're having fun
this is fun
um
strength
no we'll get that to 15 faith
all right irina what do you look oh
why are there hands here dog
who's a little pop boy
is that jar barn
hello
hello
okie dokie
what are you wearing irina
hello hello is somebody there yeah might
i bend your ear for a moment sure my
name is a servant's dad but i swear my
good father decided
let me see if i can use lightning
spirits they've since come i fear it's
please would you mind taking my soul
wishlist i would love to take that to
your dad please
that is not a letter girl
that is not a letter
that i can't give him you want me to
give him this
thank you deliver it to my phone i will
deliver that weird-ass mass to you dad
look at this thing
i'm wearing it
i wonder if i give it to him that he'll
like take it
interesting
that's a big i look so stupid
it looks so dumb
all right
we can use all these
the lightning spear
blindstone breath
um and then i have a claw mark that
really doesn't help us
but we can use these things i think
right
all right here we go boys
here we go
okay
all right that's lit we need more fp but
that's really cool
i'm megamind
this is so cool
okay uh flash allocate let's put like
let's just do a five and a two banger i
think
yeah
don't i look cool guys is this somebody
i can hurt
wow
pathetic
it's a giant spider egg sac on your head
yeah i like it
oh there's usually a giant right here
you're not a giant
poison darts
smithing two
great grave glove wart that's big
so we get from you
not using shiburi's bro well i'm pretty
sure that makes the game harder
legit like a harder game
oh there's a chest over here you're
right you're right you're right
i forget a lot about the chess
your character looks like ned flanders
in disguise
oh my god you're right
we'll check the night's calvary of
course of course of course
i even get this we're gonna try
wow that was worth
i'm really glad i did this
all right let's get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah my ned flanders smurf
excuse me
i don't really care
if you found that gross or not
okay
i really need some pants don't i
think i think we do i think we need some
pants
all right what do you have
i'm not setting
receive bell bearing okay that looks
like to be just a part of the mod
purchase ooh finger maiden here line a
puppet
that's interesting
right hauling bell smithing stones
hanukkah forgetfulness and selvius's
potion i wonder what he gives us
hey stan how are you man thank you how
are you we can get the volcano mandar
letters
firemonk's prayer book
okay i have anything to sell sure do
should i buy the summon
is uh finger maiden airliner good
hey it's irina's letter i'm gonna get
that
i really wish i didn't do that
oh well
buy the summon all right
uh should i get these like i feel like
we're gonna get
i don't think we need to buy these
because we might get the items later
i'm gonna chill on that i'm gonna chill
on that now let's check who this is
past time to nightfall
we'll we'll find pants
i'm sure of it
all right here we go what
lame it's the same
that's so lame
oh god i'm dead
howie
man that just destroys fp huh
new spear
that was my fault
i don't know what i'm doing right now
this this hat is actually distracting
like i'm not gonna cap
i need to find some sacred tears
why did i do that
so i can load that up huh okay
seems just as good
oh come on dude
you got lucky we'll take it
i hate you
all right we gotta switch to this
you like that
i got scared
of that
this hat is actually distracting
he's going a little wild right now
why do i keep doing that
i thought i could knock him off this is
going to be close boys
very close
come on
i literally didn't react i just didn't
do anything
come on
yeah
better
i'm better
better
it's just not worth it man
just not worth it at all
i don't want that [ __ ]
all right i'm putting levels into fp i
think
i think that might be a call
is it mind yeah
yep good enough
my goodness
all right let's go see what we got going
on in the castle over here this this
could be ridiculous
up like every castle we go into by the
way could be absolutely
stupid
okay those are still the maps that makes
sense
i think we still get the golden seeds in
the same places
like this should be a golden seed
it's not it's some dumb [ __ ] that we
don't want so i was
wrong there's no giant shooting at us
what what is this
wow this giant was replaced by
that huh
you still drop an item no of course not
all right
let's get it
what a weird room
you guys like my character i'm looking
pretty cool
i think i could be the voice actor for a
lot of people in this game
like a lot of random [ __ ]
like that burning zombie
change the hat
no
okay just in case we die
okay we got a jellyfish we have a bear
uh normal zombies
okay
oh [ __ ]
i can't believe you've done this
dad
whoa
okay
could you voice act the madness screams
do you want me to just start yelling
is this what you want
just heard alexander somewhere
i have alerts so anytime somebody
subscribes it's alexander going hello
so no he's not in the game
he's not here
please start
yelling there you go
it's my yell what is
is that a caleb crow
actually a good spot for him
what if i resub
uh no clue
you guys can hear godric if you become a
member just saying
and then i i made a specific
sound for uh oh god this is bad
i made a sound for uh gifted members as
well
i forget which one it is though
have any of you guys ever fought one of
these things i always run away
for reasons that are pretty apparent
oh i'm gone
see ya
yes that was a pterodactyl
i love getting another fur calling
remedy i appreciate that thank you
nope i don't fight those birds why is
there two
brah
jesus
my god
i just got annihilated
literally crowed
yes stan that was the pterodactyl sound
that you all know and love
imagine summoning someone
okay i'm going i'm beelining toward the
uh
the grace
get the spear
okay probably won't be a spear
because remember
item randomizer
yeah i don't know what nightmares
miyazaki had with birds and dogs but
pretty clear he didn't like either one
of them
pretty clear he did not have a good time
with those guys
boom boom boom boom
please okay
oh i should be using the bolt
it
oh well let's go down here
what is that you see that
a summonable
giant
excellent
imagine if patches is the elden beast
i'm actually really curious of that
but
i have to beat every
i have to get every great rune to have
access to the er tree
by the way
those aren't new
yep
we got here
a bow okay that's possible potential for
things
that is potential
hello hello
what is this
toxic mushroom
yeah but this randomizer requires two
all seven great runes
get to the elden beast you only need two
great runes to access the capital city
but that's a part of this mod
that i triggered
is that godric
oh god here we go
is that a beastman leave me alone
oh god
yep
leonine godrick
i don't have my puppet out yet
i didn't think of the puppet
this is not good
uh fp
why did i do that
but he's still gonna change
happens he doesn't even switch
let's go finger maiden
kind of just getting burned
i'm the best
that was not worth it at all guys
oh now you're using fire i see
what a delay what a delay
heal me
what does he say there
i have no idea how i'm avoiding this
it says bow before me okay
stagger man
let's go
and all the elder ring law good luck
with the randomizers stream 77 7777
thanks brent
i appreciate it man 177
777.
seven seven seven seven let me get some
sevens in the chat for brent thank you
thank you
thank you brent
when did i find a sacred tier wait did i
just earn that
i didn't i wasn't paying attention what
i got did i get the secrets here
okay it must have been
kinda worth kinda sorta
okay
um
i'm gross let's go into
i don't know what should we do now hello
hello
what should we do now
we could go anywhere we want
we got one level out of that poggers
more faith please
seven seven seven seven seven
can you burp into the mic again uh when
i have the will to burp i will the need
to burp
you guys really want to go to caleb no
i don't know you kidding me
we can't even go to radon until we get
to ulta's plateau
the plateau
on guys you know this
um let's go see who the the boat lady is
and then we have to find d
okay let's get it
elmo's world
blah
oh we could go into this catacomb
already distracted
let's do it
go feed hayeta some balls do you mean
eyes eyeballs never mind you know what
you're talking about
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven seven
okay
yep
the [ __ ]
a sombers
okay
it's just like a weird ass
is that what i think it is
favorite boss is radon 100
um
we're gonna be fine we're gonna get past
this guys trust me
hmm
just gotta weed it out
wait let me do this
decent damage
let's try the oh god
these freaking bosses man are so garbage
i can't
i couldn't lock on
there we go
that doesn't really do anything
this did a lot more
that takes a lot of fp though
let's go
all right else what else we got down
here huh
i have to use these now
this is a somber somber two
somber two boys
whoa
i didn't even know those women could
hold weapons what
what a weird combo okay i'm going this
way
hello what's this
i had that's my second great
grave gloveboard
i think that was great work
with the lever voice
that's all we needed to do is hit the
lever
got some more gauntlets
we are running we are running
[Music]
yes
it will respawn it will respawn
but we already got the door open so
we're good
flame of frenzy is the best enemy
because nobody gets maidens
but what if everyone got maidens
okay let's see what this boss is
i wonder if it'll have like three
quarters health
if only you could get my big ass head
out of the way black knife bloodhound
knife
this is actually kind of a [ __ ]
ow
dog i need you to chill
literal dog
not what i wanted to do
[Music]
got a hit there
whoa
nice
i'm half expect two
i just got three cuckoo glitz stones
from that that's great let's see what
this is
missionaries cookbook what is that
all right that was an interesting
dungeon at least this makes the dungeons
like different right
really does
hey it's let me solo her what's up dude
have you done a randomizer yet this
shit's fun
i'm gonna go for more mind cuz i keep
running out of fp
the dog slayer dude i love dogs
oh
oh no guys
i don't know what's happening
uh-oh
oh
man
dang it launch
everybody hold
everybody hold
your horses
it's gonna be a black screen for about
20 seconds
i don't know what was around the corner
for my game to crash but it must have
been something big
something very large
wait i actually need this for a second
that's me
hold on people
i need this
real quick
we gotta pull that over here
we gotta go down here
do that
and then
do that
okay let's see if we lost progress
please no
let's go
we're good
see how quick that was too
i'm so quick with it all right please
don't crash again
i might not pull out torrent for a
second
okay
we're good
we are good
okay we already helped alexander
who's gonna be on the bridge
a tiny little hand
agt stands for agents
agent jake
and
if you want to know the origin of that
it's because my name used to be
jake frst farm so is jake from state
farm
and then one day i got an email from
state farm saying that they had some
concerns with my name
and that's when i got partnered on
twitch so i was like well i don't want
to deal with that [ __ ]
so i changed it to adt jake because i
called my community at the time
the agency and you guys are gonna find
this hilarious
that when i was on twitch when people
subscribed to the channel or like became
members like you would here
we always had a saying that was we will
insure your toes
so your feet would be safe which is
really weird obviously but you guys seem
to be in defeat so we could bring that
over here if you want
but we called our the the community the
agency
which is where agent comes from
so if you become a member to the channel
i will make sure your toes are safe
no way
that was just laying there
that literally the best weapon in the
entire game
[Music]
no
way
that was just laying right there
oh
yeah
what do we need 17 decks
that is literally what we're doing
game over
all right what do you got dog oh gee yep
sorry to scare ya
yup
you sell that
i could probably sell all these as well
but let's not
i [ __ ] up
i just got so lucky bro
i really did
um
queen's bracelets bloody slash is really
good
but now that we have death's poker we're
kind to win
which heeds no summons
the stormhawk king
is this a summon what is this
who's elden rings best girl
hmm
uh all women all women are great
it's a quest item taking it
i must don't even don't even fret all
right let's go
what am i hearing over here
i heard big stomps
what is that sound
okay it's just a regular dragon
and a sorcerer
interesting
interesting wait where's d
where's these nuts
there's no mistake is the
death has left he still has the arm
animation
he's wearing samurai
this is a fit
wow
ah
a tarnish darya
i'm known as dee
i hold these nuts those who live in
death and weed that paid my warning
still the same sword
has been touched by death wait even this
chick is randomized it is home to a
mariner
okay let's see what we got going on down
here
this is usually a tibia mariner
killing him won't affect the quest line
is that the tree that's a draconic tree
sentinel
you want help with voice acting for the
path
the great path ahead i don't have
professional experience but it sounds
like fun
if
so i'm gonna at least for this first
season i'm gonna do it myself if it if
it goes somewhere i will definitely hire
people to voice act i think that would
be awesome
so be on the lookout but at least for
now i'm just gonna do it because i have
no idea how well this is gonna go at all
it's gonna be a ton of work and it could
totally flop
but that'll be fine because it's still
making something that i find really cool
bang
tibia tree circle
ow
ow
i'm going for it boys
not worth
not worth at all
could be good
excellent
more
and
let's go
what do i get
briar great shield
i'll take it
thank you
does he he gives me he marks something
on my map but i don't think he gives me
an item another foe with a prowl
how would you if you're inclined i love
how his hand is still like that
it will lead you to
red mark on the map
yeah you don't care
let's get the uh dog talisman which
won't be the dog talk
sorry won't be the dog talisman
where are the turtles
or the dogs excuse me
i want an update that removes most
filler content and adds something unique
uh
damn
these all get replaced too they're none
of them are are dogs
have a good one femi
do we got here
veterans grieves hey i do need some
pants
nice looking good
never mind get that [ __ ] out of here
i'm glad you like it gary
get the [ __ ] out of my way squirrel
uh
i wonder who spawns up here now
damn
sorry sometimes i gotta stop and just
look at this game because it's so pretty
we gotta level up our decks
what do we need
because we're using that smoker 17 decks
deal
who's attacking me
what the
okay there's some bad business going on
over there
eldon ring looks ass
are you a titties man
oh no
oh no
oh no
let me drink
i'm gonna burn you
well
that did something
stop rolling perfectly i hate that
okay both npcs i've fought so far have
had like bleed weapons
i don't think i've died to a boss
hey we gave it a try we did our best
right guys oh probably not
one hand straight sword you casual
i'm getting bad vibes from you already
i'm just saying
you can switch that up
or
you can calm down
and have fun
thanks
damn this is pretty too
river's a blood user
imagine
boom
boom
guys do you do you think stray wins game
of the year over elden ring
the cat game
okay let's see what this is
letter to patches
nomadic cookbook interesting
is he just straight up chillin
dang it
no yeah i was kidding
why are you so perfect
might be a [ __ ] watch this oh never
mind i can't
well
man his weapons are insane
eldon ring is bad
fortnite is better
okay
that's an opinion
i think you're trolling though okay dex
we got a lot more to go in the decks
department
i need 17 decks
i didn't think we would get this man
that's insane okay
where can we go to get runes
yeah i still don't have pants
i fat roll with the pants
yeah i think he's i think he's trolling
nobody thinks fortnite's better than
eldon ring
unless
you have fun playing fortnite
then obviously you're gonna think it's
better
and that's fine
[ __ ]
i think he'll dodge it every time
nope
i am terrified of you
yay
what are you gonna give me
give me give me give me
mything stone threes let's go
more rare than a somber nine to be
honest you fighting over there buddy
smithing three again golden rune i'll
take it i'll take it i'll take it
why am i going to caleb what am i doing
here
damn though
dude i got my settings on like a good
good spot right now this looks great
stop giving baguette attention
but i want to give him attention because
he's being a troll
and it's funny
hmm
let's go to stormville i think that'll
be better
let's go to the castle
we can't go to radon yet
and forge
well of course he wants attention he
doesn't get it from his parents
so he goes online
it's pretty typical
i'm surprised we aren't used to this yet
i am
i don't know about all y'all
okay every point we're getting is going
to decks
i don't need you to tell me to go
through here because guess what i'm
gonna do it
okay
let's check this
that's a big boy rune that's big that's
a level right there
so i've been a content creator guys for
are you [ __ ] kidding me i've been a
content creator for a long time
it took me a while to get used to trolls
or people just being dumb
but i cracked
okay
i did
my brain no longer functions when people
are being dumb
so don't even stress it
yo chill bear
the heck just happened
okay
let's get it this is gonna be awful by
the way
whoa
depending on what's in here
glintstone stars okay okay we got a slug
that's lit
little sluggy boy
is that that npc that's in the no they
can just be normal
club we'll take that this looks
important as well
you stay right there
excellent
crimson amber medallion
we're gonna keep this
okay really
is this
scaled oh god
beautiful
beautiful
oh boy
oh boy
probably gonna have to use this honor
right now
[Music]
i thought you were done
there
oh thank you dude
thank you aaron
appreciate the kind words and the super
chat get some w's in the chat please
thank you
that didn't take that long guys that was
fine
thank you aaron
w
what the [ __ ]
isn't this supposed to be a guy and he's
a statue
what do you got a horn for man
you can spam w's or sevens for aaron
and thank you aaron you're the best
got some different gloves
what are you doing there you need to
calm down
we got a jellyfish a non-hostile one
okay thank you
don't get hostile on me
uh this could be bad
wait that's an item
not worth at all
but thank you for all the super chats
today guys i appreciate it it's been a
lot of them
ha ha got him all right let's see if we
still get uh trapped in here
yep sure do
who's gonna be in here though
all right i definitely like this better
excellent
we got smithing stone four we have a lot
of upgrade items we just need the runes
to use them
ritual pot okay wait can i not get the
key
uh oh
we have to go through the main gate i
think
because i don't think i'm gonna like the
key isn't here
let's test
nope
that's where you normally get the key
we're gonna have to go back
yeah main gate is easy uh except when
it's a randomizer with random enemies
we have no idea what's gonna be at that
main gate
okay at least we can travel
back home
the randomizer makes it easy yeah i
earlier it was like you can't uh
some enemies can't like that jellyfish
up there is at the crossbow
and it physically can't use it
you open the main gate
what do you got
it was lion great bow
this is a good great bow
slumbering egg
these are okay i don't want to use runes
though of course when you approach it
tony okay let's get it
yes radon's great bow
oh we got three items right here
okay
smithing three
don't shoot at me
mushroom
really
what does that require
this is just a
20 strength 12 or 14 decks
oh lit
we've got this work
we're going to have an interesting build
here guys to say the least
this build is gonna be fun
it's bad but it's cool though
who's over here i'm gonna hit this
really quick
we witnessed the bear already
yeah we did we don't know who's gonna be
over here though
we don't know who's gonna be godrick
i think we still get the same amount of
runes we're just killing the boss
pretty sure that's been uh
the same
also i'm pretty sure it's gifted subs
not gifted subs gifted members or new
members and you get the uh that sound
effect
that alert will play
i don't think any of these guys can
shoot
now we're good we're good
we're getting kind of lucky another
summon
exalted flesh
whoa
okay
bad
wrong thing
going this way
leave me be
leave me be
um
yeah glintstone stars is good right i
think it is
see what this is
i've gotten three of those by the way
there's another item down here
owie
okay that item looks important
it's got a different glow to it
stone of garank and a smithing steven
i like it i like it i like it
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven seven seven
someone become a member and see dude
that's what i'm saying
there's definitely more of a i've
streamed on twitch for
five years by the way there's definitely
more of a culture on twitch for people
to sub than their like become a member
which is equivalent to subbing
uh there's more of a culture for it on
twitch than there is on youtube
clear these boys out get some random
items
okay
strip of white flesh
smithing one
smithing two
be proud no philly what the [ __ ] are you
wearing fine warrior
your only mistake was your choice of
muster
let the winds lift you
to a higher place
um
you look great well who do we have here
tarnished are you yup clearly not one of
godric's lot i am the feli lou
you sure are how utterly this grafting
is tented
[Music]
let's go aaron
thanks for becoming a member man welcome
to the tarnished
you're one of the tarnished there are
several layers to it or levels
but thank you aaron
let's get some uh
let's get some sevens in the chat
i love seven it's my favorite number
that [ __ ] hurt
yeah witness
i'm in trouble
but thank you aaron welcome dude
welcome to the agency
i need to have like more reasons for
people to become members because you
guys don't really use emotes do you
you guys don't like emotes
on youtube yet
at least i don't think so
let's see
do we still get the cut scene
these are in game
is he gonna look dumb okay no he looks
the same mighty dragon
dirty true born air
lend me thy strength o kindred there you
go aaron
deliver me let's go
greater heights
what are we five
moog the grafted
no shot
it's mogan time
this is gonna be [ __ ] hard
our man does not stagger
he mowed
he mowed on me man
what do you guys think using emotes is
like something kids do
i think emotes are fun
look at aaron's emote he has a you died
it's kind of hilarious
because i died
let's see what's over here we might have
to go somewhere else to get runes to use
death's poker and then we can upgrade it
as well
oh he's gonna take me over here dude
thanks for the leg wraps
which has animated emotes
that is true
i think you can have animated emotes on
here
i just haven't made any yet
i was thinking i i know it's possible
for especially with the new um videos
that we're coming out with
the um
the great path ahead and that like tv
show
type series
i thought it'd be fun
i thought it'd be a good idea to like if
you're a member to the channel in any
level so it's like i think it's three
bucks to become a tarnished
level member um you get a video a day
early
i think that would make sense
like that would give people a good
reason too
so
i'm thinking about that it's not a thing
yet it might be a good idea
and then it would just be out the next
day
we'll see hi metal how are you
i'm gonna pop these
see if i can get a level
moog's a glorified discord moderator
is that right
monthly q a you guys can you you guys
can ask me questions whenever you want
excuse me
all right
what are we gonna do
hmm
is every rune a piece of the elden ring
the runes i just popped yes
let's try this again
i'm gonna pop this chick
i don't think is gonna help us at all
i didn't even think he was going at me
leave me be
136
not the best
wait is he gonna do the thing
is he gonna heal
[Music]
knee heel
yeah the bow might be a play here
[Music]
all right i got it off i got it off
slowly tarnished
not unfit even to craft
um
awesome
well
i wonder if our sword will do better
damage
let's try that
hold
everybody hold i bet it won't um but it
might stagger him potentially
you delaying [ __ ]
it does 268.
that's
better that's better that's better
it's not good though
how dare you mowed the grafton
i think it might be too hard i'm gonna
try a couple more times just to kind of
get a feel for it
because honestly if we can just level
decks
and then we can level up death's poker
we're good
bro
bruh there's fire everywhere
this is a cool arena for moog
[Applause]
bloody slash is an idea
i do have bloody slash
isn't moog weak to blood
it's a skill issue it really is i don't
have the whetstone
didn't we see it somewhere i forget what
merchant we saw it on
why is he weak to blood that's weird
he's a lord of blood
oh
hold on
came out she had thrown up twice
[Music]
he's not going to be allowed outside
anymore it seems
looks like joy puked everywhere
oh
oh
well
that's bad
i think she's okay though
did you join late i started a couple
hours ago let's see i'm trying to think
craft blood arrows i mean how much is
the
i have the short though do you think
it'll do enough
we can try it
let's see
not
not uh
nope
not the best there
i have poison darts
now
did those miss
it didn't even poison them
moog is kinda nuts boys
wow
this gonna be tough
we already knew this
[Music]
yeah i got i think i got bloody slash i
bought it
who i have to go to uh
i don't have the whetstone to do it here
but i could do it here
it could be something because the sword
isn't bad
at all i could also upgrade it
it's not that uh like we're gonna use
the sombers yeah yeah
hold on
so we could do that but i need runes
that'd be fine
dude i thought i had something to sell
do i have a stick
i could get those back
right got no stick
if the bells that doesn't mean i can use
the whetstone i haven't had the
whetstone yet
can i turn these in
and then i might
hold
is this what we want
and a secrets here
yeah i think we just have to go
somewhere else we really do we got we
gotta go somewhere else
for now
where could we go
yeah cold infuse is actually really good
could we go
we could go around
grail
oh [ __ ] you're right do you think you
look different
that could be a lot of runes what the
[ __ ]
is this a chained
look at this
okay
interesting
a chain giant there
we
hmm
are these guys dead already
now let's go let's let's focus
let's focus
there are a lot of items out here that
we can just grab and maybe get something
really good out of it
let's go this way
he fell from the tree
interesting
we're getting how to get to grail from
here i have to go this way
oops
i could skip the lorena
we could do that
dang i wish we knew we were gonna get
death's poker
that changed the whole game man that
that is quite literally the best weapon
in the game i'm pretty sure
no
choir dragon rot
you fail to realize that this is all
completely random
we have
no ability to know what we are going to
get
for every item we pick up
so that's a good idea
but we can't
nice
there's a lot of items down here
we'll break this guy over here as well
we'll go check and see if grail is still
a giant dragon it doesn't look like it
because that looks weird as hell
it was weird as hell
i could lead him over
to the uh yeah this way
go that way
go go go go
go go go go go go
fall
ball
oh
thank you
bye-bye
blood boom okay
that's a thing
we'll take it
obviously
let's go down here
a lot of items
ow
we got an important one here so we got
magic grease
somber for
malakat's helm
not the best grab here but i will take
the helmet because it's
wow
i kind of look amazing
don't i
the only answer is yes you look great
the ball grinding method what is that
would you guys like the dude helm or
this helmet
uh grail is still grail
this would get us enough runes though
did we kill him
it would take us forever i don't even
know how we would
sounds boring
um
oh it's a her sorry
trying to think just knowing that we
don't know what we're gonna get
is what makes this a little hard
bloody slash okay let's go back to the
round table
because if we can make him bleed that's
pretty good like he he's pretty prone to
bleed
and now i have runes
we can upgrade this
yeah yeah wow
okay ash is a war on here
didn't i get bloody slash guys
i swear i did
didn't i buy it i might be tripping
well let's do that i mean it's something
right
can you not put bloody slash on the
sword
maybe i didn't buy it
i didn't
oh do you remember where it is
i got the bell bearing for you i turned
in all my bell bearings this is not
there
i didn't have the scratch gotcha
it's hard to remember
it's not here
unless i have to do this
harry and grandeur
it's where you found d's
was it that merchant
the one over here
right here
i think it is
there it is it's 8k
i bought this instead [ __ ]
do you do we ever use these
that's 5k
still isn't going to be enough
i'm never gonna use these either
damn we're still short i can just go
kill [ __ ]
yeah we freed alexander
kill the surroundings to properly kill
grail
does killing the surroundings change
that
don't think so
oh i just got all the runes i need
i'm killing that one guy
there we go
whoa what the heck are you
okay
a wolfy boy
they share hp
i did not know that that's cool
oh there anything okay let's sell this
there's 5k right there do you guys think
bloody slash is gonna be worth it
i think it can help us kill moog
just for the blood infuse right
yeah we're get we're definitely gonna
use that's poker we're pretty much gonna
it's like an investment that's what
we're doing here
we're putting it on this
so that we can kill moog so we can use
the runes to be able to use death poker
well i took my battery i had your own
don't you think
blood
excellent
all right upgrade it
not for now
so all i need to do is use it now right
guys like i don't have to use bloody
slash
or will it apply a bleed
just regularly
you take damage when using it
lead on hit as per normal
so never mind
could i put
the other ash of war on it
blood boon as well good point
because these those are pretty much
trash
can't use it i need 17 arcane bro
howard glintstone
see what man
not without the wet stone
all right let's get it let's get it
it works if you don't use the effect so
if i'm just hitting him
it'll apply
bleed that's what you're saying
don't need to use the ash war to cause
bleed okay
okay
i just have to get good it's a skill
issue right now
did i still use it
doesn't require a lot of fp
it hurts me a bit
what
what did he just do
to graft
this seems like the regular moog
should one hand the weapon it does way
less damage though
wasn't it
i'm not using either one of those
check the sword in the why what
what about the sword
what
take that off i'll put this on
yeah we knew it was causing bleed right
fire did not do much
okay
why am i hurt back
it's the lord of blood moog
can you tell
i can't even use glenstone star shards
um
[ __ ] we could try the stone
maybe he doesn't like rocks in his face
not bad damage at all
that's something boys that's something
that one i didn't charge
bruh the range
[Music]
please don't throw
is he gonna heal me boys
it's kind of stuck
no
too far away
no i thought you were stuck
wrongly tarnished
not unfit even to graft guys the bloody
slash
is not doing nothing
he is not i don't think i guess i didn't
hit him enough
yeah we have no idea where that flask is
that wasn't bad though we're making
progress we are
stronger than we were
man
it dude gotta get good right
oh
i think we got to go somewhere else i
think we have to go around
i really think we do
we are simply not strong enough for that
we could be here all day and try and do
it
uh why am i here i want to
[Music]
go we could i i think we could do it
but
let's just go around
moog is a hard boss to have there man
definitely
that's hard to [ __ ]
let's go around
[ __ ] you
[Music]
are the finger maidens gonna look
different
no
i could summon the feli
that's a good point
i just don't think i had her dialogue
enough to get her to do it
i still think it would be kind of
ridiculous
and she would die really quick
we'll come back we'll come back hello
loretta not loretta
lieutenant
god
sorry
don't shoot me
okay we're good
what will your line be if you were a
boss
hmm
that's a good question
what the [ __ ]
it will lead me wait can i go down here
guys
without beating godric
or where godric would be
i'm lost
yeah it would be
my boss line would be
i am the protector of toes
they are all mine
give me your toes
then i just start attacking you
my special ability is i suck your toes
no jump attacks are not cheese
looking good dude you're tarnished don't
you
no
you're right who's this
man that's bad
you're tarnished then believe it or not
i'm not giving you [ __ ] i need those
[ __ ] you
would that be my uh
when i kill you
you have not made the agency
you are unwelcome
lord jake agent of toes
number two we'll take it
what kind of build are you going for uh
well we found death's poker
so we're building off of that
we need more points to decks
fortunately we just lost a bunch of
runes
yep that's why i'm wearing this helmet
you're new surprise no matter what i
don't this guy talks a lot um
receive bell bearing
excellent purchase what do you got
he has two golden seats
both priced very differently solves his
introduction
uh
what wow
sir
finally [ __ ] off finally
would you kindly how are we gonna get
into the academy
this thought of that
i don't need the map [ __ ] it
yeah i know we need the glintstone key
but we don't know where that's gonna be
oh let's go find out
yeah the key word is there it should be
in the same place
what are you
roar medallion
worthless literally worthless
did the merchant i just passed actually
sell it
who replaced margaret it was uh
who was it
i forget
was it loretta no who was it
oh
newman rune
that's a big rune
not as big as i thought oh yeah it was
rinala
that was very interesting
you could go back like an hour and watch
it if you want that's the cool thing
about youtube streaming is you could go
back and then you're like oh that was
cool and then stream just go right back
to where you were
or to live
oh
how much do we need
we need one more level guys one more
level
i'm pretty sure we could beat moog if we
get this death's poker
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i don't want to talk about it
17 decks
let's try that one again
there we go
bye you're
let's see what we get here
one crest wouldn't shield
runar
mimick's avail
well
we got our level
just an elden remembrance
on the ground
[Music]
wow
that was the worst guy to have
there where is there a stake of america
over there what
hey stasny
totally worth
totally worth
where the
what the
take me over here
and get ratagon's hammer
uh we don't want that
we want dust poker
100
all right let's get our level let's go
upgrade that's poker and then i think we
can fight mogu but i am curious about
this key first
yes the poker is way better than you
guys think
uh level up
x
i'm gonna save all the runes i can go
back here
what makes it good it's uh
you'll see
oh it's 11 intelligence as well i wasn't
even paying attention to that cute
11 inch
oh we're good
excellent
we have that
i think we have sombers
we definitely have sombers
we don't have a three
uh was anyone selling a three
i'll show you guys though
i'll show you
uh we already did the invasion down
below it was like some random thing
[Music]
i don't think there's any sombers here
okay
let's literally go try moog again
i think we only need this
yep
i should have spent my runes what am i
doing dude
i went into this way too quick
oh no
i have to wait for the frost to wear off
can i just exit
[ __ ] i didn't even think of that
he's gonna plot me back out there
or whatever white
okay thank you
okay so what is this level with
strength and dex let's get it
20
uh whoa okay
an inch
need more in there
let's go
don't walk that way what are you what
what are you doing
there we go
dude i hate that attack
could do
the other thing
if i get close
and have a moment
bruh
i just have him walking it's pretty good
that's unfortunate
i'm not playing scared i'm waiting for
him for the effect that we're off so i
can do it again
thank you
because we want to get that uh
it does a lot of damage
there we go
[Music]
oh
damn i'm gonna die to the knee heel
so
man this is gonna be so hard holy [ __ ]
man
so i pretty much can't get hit
i don't think we can kill him before the
transition
see how much does this do if i just
nice throw idiot
26 52
yeah i definitely have to wait for the
effect to wear off
there we go
does decent damage
i also do good damage just hitting it
slowly
okay that changes a lot
we're figuring it out we're figuring out
guys calm down let me figure it out
let me test
if we come to the conclusion later that
we can't do it then we won't do it i
think it's possible because i can hit
him
then maybe we wait for stage two to use
the effect
let me let me let me try it out a bit
more
now i feel like i'm not doing anything
yeah what's going on
what did i hit him for
before
oops
was it while he was in this stage
his summon let me solo her i don't think
you can summon when you're using a mod
that's the thing we don't know where
tears are
i think we gotta get the effect off
have him walk in it
this is doable
i just need to not be bad
it should wear off
oh your timing is so insane
it was a little early there too bad
stop walking to the side
walk forward
damn it
there we go
he doesn't say knee heel
this is gonna be absolutely ridiculous
stop walking to the side for no reason
nice
he is so aggressive
come on
get the effect
it's it's not even doing anything now
this is a no-go
man bro
yep i think that kind of solidified it
this is a no-go for right now
i think that did it
i was like maybe for a second there for
a little bit
and that yeah it's like yeah okay
that's a big old nope right there
see i threw fire at him earlier and it
didn't do anything
why am i here
i would like to be here please
would fire deprock the foss ross i i
actually didn't think we could stack
rocks that's true
so we could like
frost them
then ghost flame them then bleed them
then poison them
and all those stack
let's see what's over here
and i could have done more melee as well
that's true
in the second phase
facts
fire pots could
or we go somewhere else get stronger and
come back
right right
why does he look more like a demon i
don't think he looks more like a demon
still a dragon here
they both what do you mean by demon they
both look like omens
stay over there
ziki's decay
is like skis could decay owl of shabri
finger maiden robe old fang okay we
don't have the key
is this morales
who are you
oops
yep
um
there
he's a moon immune to frost i'm pretty
sure i just proc them so he's not immune
yeah
he's getting hit pretty good there too
yep
man's just got
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] up
i don't think what
i don't think it's frost
is what i'm talking
i forget what it is though is it just
ghost flame
walk forward
or is it actually frost
fall over man
ghost flame is for us
what
one shot huh
holy [ __ ] i'm getting annihilated
all right
oh
vigor is definitely checked here boys
we're gonna pick this up
on
what day is it today what is today
what is the what is the the day of the
week
because i gotta go take care of joy i
think she's sick
which is not good
i'm getting updated texts as we speak
it's saturday so we're gonna pick this
up on monday
because tomorrow
we are going to start bloodborne
that's right get excited
so we're gonna go like here's how the
streams are gonna go
tomorrow we're gonna play bloodborne the
next day we're gonna do randomizer again
day after that we're gonna do bloodborne
day after that we're gonna do randomizer
again cool
give me a
seven in the chat if you like that
and then in between streams i'm gonna be
working on the uh the great path ahead
which i'm gonna try and get the first
episode out by the end of the month
um
that's my goal
and then release episodes once a week
seven seven seven seven excellent
so it's gonna be like a series now
rather
and then once i'm done with it i'm gonna
combine it all together into one movie
which i think is the better way to go
about it
but
look forward to that look forward to
bloodborne tomorrow around the same time
11 a.m cst that's when i'm gonna start
um
let's get it boys i had a lot of fun
today this randomizer is really fun it
gets kind of hard though no kidding we
had it easy at the beginning like
everything was going really well and
then we hit moog where godric is and
that is uh
that's gonna be a test but we can do it
so
i'm out here guys
have a fantastic rest of your day
and we'll be back tomorrow with
bloodborne right
i'll see you guys have a good one i'm
gonna go take care of jojo
bye dudes